(bass and drums)
- Hey, I'm Adam.
I come from a jazz and rock background.
- I'm Nahre.
I come from a classical piano background.
- And I'm LA and I come from a gospel
and hip-hop, R&B background.
- [Nahre] And we're gonna chat
about some of our thoughts
surrounding learning by ear
versus learning with sheet music.
- And then we're gonna jam
- Yes
- and put all this to test.
- It's gonna be dope.
- Yes,
(laughs)
agreed.
(electronic jazz)
- Whoo, play it, Nahre, go ahead!
- Before I started lessons,
I just really liked the keyboard
and then I copied what
my teacher was doing,
but you can only keep that
up to a certain point.
If you don't know how to
read, you're outta luck.
(electronic jazz)
- I would play to records in my basement,
playing to Beyonce, a
concert, watching the DVDs.
- Nice.
That's how I learned,
you know what I'm sayin',
arrangements.
- Watching.
Watching is just as important
as a high percent of playing.
(electronic jazz)
- I started by learning piano
and then I learned how to play bass
because there was a band starting
and they just needed a bass player,
and I promptly stopped playing piano
and I said, like, this is the cool thing,
yeah, I'm gonna learn.
- Sorry, Nahre.
(laughs)
(electronic jazz)
- [LA] Yeah.
- [Adam] That was it.
- Cool.
- That was a tune, that was a tune.
- [LA] Now are you, wait,
you don't know how to jam?
That's perfect.
- I've never jammed like this before.
Well, this is such a relief
because we've always been communicating
via video talk and everything
but this is,
this is where--
- In person.
- Making music together.
- You guys are playing, yeah.
The first time you guys get to play.
- Hit together at the same time, yeah.
In gospel music, as far as
the energy is concerned,
a level one is, like, the basic groove.
Level two is the bridge,
it's the next level energy,
and level three is the vamp.
That's where all the craziness happens,
all the extra chords, hits,
lines, all that, level three,
and you gotta end on level three.
(bass and drums)
All right.
This'll be a good thing
to do them solos on.
Level one, level two, level three.
Try that.
It's on you.
- Level one?
- [LA] It's on you.
It's level one.
(piano begins)
- One thing I realize about,
you know, in this setting,
is we have to be sensitive
and honorable.
Level two right here.
Three, four.
(slow jazz)
- Sometimes this sort of situation's hard
because you're so used to
wanting music to be good
or right and this exercise is
much more about opening up.
(slow jazz)
- [LA] We're going to level three.
You got to go level three
so really let it all out.
(intense fast jazz)
- It does take awhile to
get into that mindset,
especially if you've never done it before,
which is crazy, Nahre,
that this was your first time doing this.
- Yeah.
- It was magic.
- We just, like, went nuts.
- I'm used to reading
cues in a different way.
In classical music there's
usually a designated person,
in a string quartet it'll
be the first violinist,
and everyone will pay attention to them.
(slow funky jazz)
- One skill that I
learned, so just in church,
that isn't taught in school
is the skill of lip reading,
being able to play while
you're still reading
and understanding and then
process that information
and translate it over to your instrument.
(funky jazz)
Pull out the bridge, my man.
Keep goin', keep goin'.
(intense drums)
Okay.
- [Nahre] That helps, level
one, level two, level three.
- I played a gig with
the Minnesota orchestra.
So it was at this church,
we were doin' this gospel concert thing,
and I could not watch the conductor.
For my world,
this,
- That's the downbeat.
As soon as, this is the ichthus,
as soon I get down there,
that's when the note should come out.
So it's like, buh.
Classical is, uhn.
(laughs)
- There's apparently a
good reason for that.
It's for the conductor to telegraph
what it's supposed to be.
- Especially because every
conductor is different.
- Yeah.
- Some are very ahead of the
beat and some are very exact.
- So it's like once you learn
the language of following
the conductor you have
to fine tune the language
to the specific conductor
that you're, okay.
That's really hard to do.
I had to watch the violinists.
I had to watch their bows for the rhythm.
I was close to them.
I didn't know what else
to pay attention to.
(slow music)
So to me, in church you're going,
are we going to the next part?
That's all I need.
- Yeah, but that to me is amazing.
How can you follow all those cues,
know what's going on based on the context
and retain all of that
information musically
and be able to improvise over it?
- Hey, Nahre, find something
cool that you wrote,
your thing, find a cool
chunk that we can jam on.
(funky jazz)
I'll find you wherever you go.
I'll find you.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [LA] Wow.
- [Adam] This is it.
I tell my students, the
more you move your body,
the better your time will be.
- Yeah.
(funky jazz)
- [LA] Yeah, yeah!
- For the longest time I didn't
get the music in my body.
- That's kind of where I struggle.
(funky jazz)
- Yeah, just try it again, try it again.
Try it again, Nahre.
Try it again.
Find it there, find it there.
You got it.
Do it again, do it again.
- I visualize lines or shapes.
Do you guys visualize
anything in your heads
while you're playing?
- I can look at a lot of
different kinds of sheet music
and be able to hear it in my head,
which I think is one of
the interesting things
about reading music
versus not reading music.
- When I'm playing I try
to pretend like I'm already
on the stage.
Now, Nahre, for you that would
be visualizing 5,000 people
in a concert hall,
- No.
solo piano.
- No, no, no, no, no.
(laughs)
- Black shawl.
Black shawl killin'.
- Riotous applause.
(laughs)
- Got to visualize the outfit, too.
You know what I'm sayin'?
- In a prom dress.
(laughs)
(fast music)
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Yeah.
(laughs)
- Come on.
- That was a metronome, though.
- No.
That was a lot, that was a lot.
- We'd like to thank
Adam for jamming with us
and also if you haven't already,
please check out his new video
discussing whether or not
playing to a backing track
is considered cheating.
(electronic music chord)